hi everybody this is chen fayou from
university group of msia this is joining
work with lei and nan from our group it
is also a joint work with msi system
group
nua the modern corners of chinese
mythology is known as creating humanity
and repairing the pillar of heaven we
name our work and neura because in this
talk we ask how to enable ai with the
ability of newer to create repair and
even edit the visual world around us
let's talk about what and why first
what is visual content creation
visual content creation aims to create
edit and contribute visual materials to
the online world so why do we focus on
these newer materials in one word they
are crucial for business
evidence have shown that people retain
any percent of what they see and human
brain processes images 60 000 times
faster than text
cool right
and naturally images and videos attract
wider audience for different regions
you will not need to translate your ads
or products to different languages a
picture is worth thousand words
talking about the trend eighty-six
percent of business use video and
marketing tour in 2021 this was 81
in 2019 and just 63 percent in 2017
an amazing study shows that 96 percent
of people have watched the industry your
video to learn more about the product or
service in 2021 and most importantly
people are twice like to share video
with their friends than any other media
in 2021 in summary video content is
powerful and visual content creation is
crucial especially for business
although visual content creation is
crucial it is never an easy step even
creating the jaw content is quite time
consuming you may search for the
internet but you may face pattern issues
you may take a photograph by yourself
but you may have to buy a camera and
find a place and maybe spend a long day
to finally find what you want you will
do by yourself but it is slow and
require rich experience
however visual content creation is more
than these draw content
you need to further edit them for
example you may need to add some
animations change the styles remove the
background and so on to achieve this you
have to learn how to properly use
photograph or movie maker to create or
edit visual contents and after all these
time consuming stuff these visual
content can be finally posted online to
create values and bring business profits
as a result more and more tech giants
turn their attention to understand
create and even edit visual contents
in this year opening ai proposed story a
12 billion gpt 3 which has strong zero
shot ability to generate images from
text descriptions
in this year google proposed mum a
powerful search engine for both visual
and language information understanding
in this year facebook proposed mental
universe to provide a better user
experience for example creating visual
reality for users
that's why we propose a newer our goal
is to build a large-scale pre-training
model to enable controllable
transformations between text image and
video and help creators to improve their
content creation or editing productivity
for training with big data large model
uniop and cv technologies newer supports
free style transformations in this
visual world in talk let's start with
three basic transformations they are
text image transformations text video
transformations and image video
transformations
this graph shows the relations between
these transformations the text on the
top is the c waves are beating the shore
and the corresponding image on the left
shows a beautiful sensor with waves and
cloud and the right is a corresponding
video and we can see the action of
beating the show so what the newer does
is enable controllable transformations
between the three modalities for example
textual text
text image generation image text
generation text video generation video
text generation and image to video
generation
let's come to the first part in the
first part we focus on visual generation
that is controllably generate images or
videos
to generate images or videos with
several frames we use we could gain to
pre
pre-process them first input image x
with a size of capital w
times capital h times three a c a
encoder is used to encode the raw image
then with the help of a learnable visual
dictionary the encoded features are
quantized into discrete tokens we can
see that the resulting discrete matrix z
has a smaller size of
small tablet times small h times three
then these discrete tokens are mapped
and fed into a cn decoder to reconstruct
the original image further a cn
discriminator is used to discriminate
whether the image is real or not
in summary we hogan can be used to
convert between continuous images and
discrete tokens so we can view v2 again
as a visual tokenization
of visual information
here is architecture of our model it
contains three parts the language input
part visual input part and the visual
output part as we can see the visual
tokens are generated auto regressively
by connecting all the language
information and locally
context with visual information an
important
design here is that we only separate in
quality color by modalities instead of
input and output we can see that the
visual input and the visual output are
in the same decoder
we designed this because we asked the
model to learn common sense knowledge
shared between images and videos this
design enables newer with a strong zero
shot ability for video generation
in addition this design enables our
model supporting plenty of downstream
visual generation tasks for example you
can simply input text and ask a newer to
generate a proper image just as story
but it can do much more than that you
can generate videos from text even
generate the videos with a restriction
of both text and image you can also ask
for visual to visual translation for
example input image and ask prediction
future frames of the image video
generation has never been so simple with
newer
let's talk about some implementation
details here firstly we use data
augmentation to improve the
generalization ability we use this video
as example we first randomly sample a
clip an original video and resize a
randomly clocked crop it's into a square
we further conduct a horizontal flip on
the video since the semantic
representation will keep the same we
also conduct a culture here which
randomly changes the brightness contrast
and saturation of a video
for text to image and text video
generation we also use the video clip to
choose the best video or image that
matches the input text best
video clip is trained separately and has
a strong zero shot ability for visual
and language matching
to train a large-scale real generation
model we incorporate three kinds of
parallel training the tensor model
parallelism
divides self-attention operations
between gpus
the pipeline parism divides layers
between gpus like that as well and the
data parallelism as we all know divided
data between gpus like that
we change these three versions of nuva
newer faces chain of 7000 text video
pairs and we add multi dataset
supporting for medium and large version
the final large model has 1.72 billion
parameters with a resolution of 336
times 336 and it takes a month to finish
the training
now let's see what newer can do firstly
let's generate some images from text
let's start from some easy ones a woman
is talking in an interview
pretty cool right how about adding some
feelings a sad looking puppy staring at
the camera
the puppy really looks sad let's try
some hard ones a small closed toilet in
a cramped space
the toilet is very small let's try a
very specific description a black and
white landscape photograph of a black
tree on a foggy autumn morning i think
this is poetry right
so how about the generating images with
exactly layout we want for example we
want a vast with flowers like this
strange shape and it is on a table
beside a wall and the generation results
cool right and you can try some more
complex things like a giraffe and zebra
a large building and even a messy room
with a lot of things
generating images are necessary for
creating the visual world but it is not
sufficient
here we talk about more changing tasks
that is creating videos directly from
text for example a person is preparing
some art what would the model generate
someone is drawing a flower or something
let's try another one a clip showing a
computer screen which
contains instructions
cool right
and
most samples
like minecraft or put egg into the water
so how about generated video as you wish
just like a director
yes you are can do that
let's say if you have a video scratch
like a man is working in a room and the
generation result would be
cool right let's see another example
this seems to be an outside thing and
the general video is
yeah
another two examples with screen and
skin are also showing here
let's try something interesting what if
we got an image and we want to predict
the video in the future for example
let's give you a hawk on the sea what
you are gonna imagine the hawk just
catches some fish interesting right
and if you are taking a plane and see
the outside window what would you
imagine
the camera is moving
how about a sony board or cam leg
this is not a calm leg it is choppy and
the final sample shows how the workflow
cascades down
cool right
creatine is a crucial ability but a good
content creator can not only create them
but also
repair or edit them just like newer who
repairs the pillar of heaven for example
give a picture of a lighthouse on the
show what if we want to make it
disappear that is easy you just tell you
all that there is no light house here
there is only beach and sky in this
region
and this is the generated result
so
deletion is okay but what about adding
something for example this is a
wallpaper on the windows
shop desktop what if we want a horse
running on the grassland newer can do
that too and how about
and how about changing something like
i want a polar bear here
cool right and what if we just want to
change the part of object in the image
like this young man may have interviewed
and
let us find him a suit for this guy
that's it
easy
as pie and interestingly you can make
these images move easily like this
let's try something crazy
wouldn't you will change the history
like change things
goes
for example this man is climbing down
the wooden hole wooden wall
what if
we want to let him climb up the wooden
wall
yes you are can do that and for this
clause if you do not like them you can
ask neura to let them float over the sea
you can even let a car reversing and
even shaking amazing right
that's the first part in the second part
let me introduce my colleague lay and
she will introduce neura for the
language generation
okay now i will introduce noir model
from the other direction vision to
language tasks including image text and
video to text task these tasks are also
called viral captioning given an image
or a video the goal is to generate a
sentence to describe the viral content
so automatically text generation from
unstructured perceptual impulse has
become an important challenge for
community uh computer vision and
multimedia information retrieval
communities
solving it can be useful for video
indexing and retrieval assistance for
the virtually impaired automatic
question generation and answering about
the environment for robotics and the
real-time generation of video captions
for civilian system so in the following
talk i will first introduce the model
architecture and then
introduce several experimental results
as well as the real application
scenarios in our product vision and
language training has achieved
impressive performance on many
downstream tasks in the talk we present
this
generic pre-training and fun tuning
framework as part of our newer model
this framework is an end-to-end
generated pre-training framework for
generation tasks the model architecture
is a typical encoder and decoder
framework on one hand we treat this
model from both image text pairs and
video text pairs there are relatively
good high quality image text data which
is used to train a good image model
and one frequently adopted strategy for
video network is to initialize it by the
pre-trained image network as a video is
a temporal sequence of image frames this
transformer based architecture is
flexible and allow us to
join with variable lens sequences
and image is actually taken as a single
frame video so on the other hand to
effectively train the model we adopted
two stage training in the first stage we
mainly train the encoder to learn a
better multimodal representation and in
the second stage we train the generative
decoder to generate the sentence and
fine-tune the encoders as well
we're mainly focusing on three tasks
including the image captioning video
captioning as well as control the image
captioning the controlled condition
here is a trees of the image which i
will introduce later
so we directly adopt the wow pre-trained
clip model from openai which is trained
from four
over 400 million text and image pairs
and then we further preaching our model
using the video and tax pairs on over
100 million text and video pairs from
how to 100 web data set so the viral
backbone is the vit base the variant
transformer which divides the image into
a 32 plus 32 sized patches and the input
with
49 patches
so since the video processing is very
time consuming and resource consuming it
takes over a half of the one and a half
of the day to complete one epoch on 64 v
100 gpus for video and language
pre-training
here is the video captioning result as
shown in the table which achieved the
state-of-the-art results and widely used
msr vtt dataset and also we shown some
of the examples
we have shown one of the example on the
left side this is a perfect match
and on the right side we have several
other interesting cases
the first example shows that the model
is capable of generating sentences with
different alternates but the same
semantic meaning with ground truth like
the object painted x are the same with
the toys in prediction
the second showcase present that the
model can describe the viral content
from different perspectives
the ground choose captioning focuses on
the ballroom but our model focuses on
the actions
besides we also found that both the text
and audio in the video are actually
important for the captioning in the
third case the self-driving car is the
focus of the video but not the man so in
this case we need ocr techniques to
actually understand
the car in this video and in the last
case the audio is important we need to
the model to listen to the video to
actually understand what they are
actually talking about
so next this is a controlled image
caption result the controlled caption is
a trees
uh here in order to understand the
details of the image as well as the
customized captioning the trace is the
most natural signal to control which
part in the image to describe
people can select the partial they want
to the agent to describe through the
trees
from the qualitative experiment we can
see that our model achieves the best
result and outperforms the
state-of-the-art result in large margin
and the trees is very important for
generating customized description
from the quantitative experiment the
shown case here that
on one hand different colors correspond
to the description in the same color
compared with the baseline which is
without the trees and the ground truth
the model can generate some details of
the image for example the blue and
purple part in the image which is missed
in the baseline prediction and also the
baseline prediction didn't follow the
trees to describe
so finally i will describe two real
scenarios applied to our product
for image captioning
in powerpoint there is already a
function called alt text which can
generate an alternative text for a given
image the function is shown on the right
side by clicking the button generate a
image
description for the image it can
generate a sentence with the confidence
and similarly it can also generate the
captions for short videos
especially the g
formatted files and this
video is actually generated by chanvay
the second real scenario is in being
radio search in the search detailed page
for some of the videos the video chapter
function is provided
the long video is structured into
several chapters each chapter is a
present with the timeline of each
chapter with the start and end time and
the sub nail of the image as well as a
sentence description with this feature
people can quickly search inside the
video overview the video content or skip
directly to the interesting part
many platforms are trying to support
this feature most of which rely on the
struct data uploaded by the human to the
website
to sum up we highlight the three of our
source
first our nature language processing and
computer vision tend to be unified
including backbone
representation as well as a pre-training
task for written backbone viral
transform is becoming the new trend and
many recent works tries to improve the
vision transformer by taking the
advantage of a conclusion
and for the reputation for matt and the
chief mentioned this great viral tokens
are important for viral content creation
this discredit viral token technique is
also important for visual and text
understanding
secondly multi-modal ai becomes an
innovation frontier
for viral and language representation
most of the current vision and language
pre-training focuses on learning a
universal vision language representation
which is not only important for
multi-modal tasks but also important for
visual and text only tasks especially
for the
recently text guided viral
representation learning like clip from
the open ai
for the content creation
both retrieval retrieving or creating
real content are important for the
online world but currently a retrieval
results are of high quality but it's
hard to deal with non-existing ones
while generation models are creative for
the new content but it may suffer from
the efficiency of accuracy
another promise in research direction is
common sense knowledge from viral corpus
the current captions for the image lack
of details and clarification of the
common sense knowledge like the human is
playing the ball but not what is not
happening like the man is not sleeping
or the man is not drinking this
knowledge can be learned from the real
world instead of the text world
finally viral content creation leads
novel ai applications an intuitive way
is a multi-modal search engine question
answering dialogue system either very
only or text only query can not fully
represent the intention of the user
especially for something new
and and
the rule encode input plus a text
description are complementary to each
other for a perfect input another
ambitious goal is ai assistant image and
video editing chenfe already showed
promising results for text controlled
visual creation editing in the long term
we are thinking to create a new
generation of viral editing tool for
controlled visual editing
thanks for listening
you